あっはぁ磯釣りだみんなあ今日はドクター始めた久しぶりだ
私が縛って廊下に出ていたったらの説明をしろオフィサードクター始められるとどうか
がかなりの確率で炎上する
来なかったなので今日はどんなに炎上しなさそうな絶叫にどうぞとって良いことを
ガッハ smarty 通夜の朝6時だ
今日の実験だからみんながそうだ10分の使っているだろうかまあ一般的なソファーと
いうばこちらこういうタイプのソファーよく見かけると申すは以後ほどそんな悪くない
がそれではこちらのソファーが一般的にや
山手だってっ
ま健気なせてすばりこざいんですけどものっぺりしてて来てねほんとにこれは人として
ダメになってしまうジェレイド進化を衰退させる可能性がある常に危険な双方の一つと
認められているというわけで今日は今までにないとファーを皆さんに見せよ多分
こちらなんとこれがソファになるのですそれにもちろん飛び可能なソファーなのでこの
ままでどこでも持っていける
すぐ作ってみよう
ますめっちゃ小さいなぁおっ金どこでも書いて持ってくるんですよとかをこれで
ふかふかのソファが作れます作ってみよう
[音楽]
巻ラスト白いですこれがセンチないでしょうか
レガースオーバー本日は空気だけなんですけどもねれますおおーー
ダメ
寝るがこれあんなにコンパクトだってってが外だったら
バタバタして空気を入れるだけでこの側のどこでもすぐ作れちゃう超高機能な近未来が
出そうかそこで私は思った
この県未来のサーバーこの部屋人に置きまくると最高の快適空間が作って出せるのでは
ないかとだというものはなかなかバスをとってしまうもののこれ一つにとってもかなり
場所をとる人だ
れてるぞも良く汗に引っかかってうざい頑張っておくだけでも結構場所とってしまうが
これはなんとこれくらいの形からこんな大きくなるので中濃をすごいラッキー様となれ
ばいつでも片付けることができる2月大量の a はソファーを購入置きまくっても
そこだけちょっとあのうぜってなると思うんですけどもうちょい日付れるっていうねな
安心感がある中どれだけ旋回してもなんか子芋銭あった
残れないというかなんかいつでも片付けられるなぁと思ってやってるんでなんか
別に山って感じなんですけどもうどこを見渡してもパワーはこの部屋塩やソファで
満たすとしてエラーソファで守れるつけたこの部屋はどこにどう飛び込んでも空気の
事件によって守られ違うすることが限りなく0%に近いと思われる
まさに神今日はそんな神の部屋を作って私自身が神になろうと思ってはいない
[音楽]
最高な服だけでどんどん作っていきましょうイクーッ
car
ねええええ
ラバー
3つでこの圧力高校とか楽しいかなはっはー
はいというわけである分でも膨らませてみたんですけど
フ
ね号骨が良さそうなのは分かったなんか息苦しいずはこれだと
はーい
どうだ能力完成したこれがおそらく世界で一番快適な嘘ファンの空間
あっはっだ魅力的な空間ならこれならどこで飛んでも気持ちシート声と彦では待った芸
体かありません
早速飛び込んでみましょう
tee
4日
だめだん
me
teame
teal
me
ana あああっ
th